The ending of Avengers: Infinity War raised
a lot of questions for the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, especially the fourth
Avengers movie, set to premiere in May 2019.
It's impossible to talk about this movie without
getting into spoilers, so if you still somehow
haven't seen Infinity War, we'll let Mark
Ruffalo fill you in.
"Wait'll you see this next one, everybody
dies."
"Dude!"
"Not everybody…"
Thanos' quest to retrieve the six stones of
the Infinity Gauntlet ends with fatal consequences
for many of Earth's mightiest heroes, with
characters being thrown off cliffs, strangled,
exploded, and ultimately turned into ash.
But as dire as the ending seems, it's unlikely
that all those dearly departed heroes will
stay that way for long, especially considering
many of the supposedly deceased have already
been confirmed to appear in Avengers 4.
Whether it's via flashback, time travel, or
convenient resurrection, it's clear that many
of our favorite fallen heroes will be returning
from the grave.
While the question of how remains mysterious,
here's a rundown of all the superheroes confirmed
to return for Avengers 4.
Ant-Man
Ant-Man appears to have made it out alive
by simply not showing up.
After sitting out the events of Avengers:
Infinity War, Paul Rudd's Scott Lang will
be back in action for the fourth team-up movie.
As far as Black Widow knows in Infinity War,
Scott was busy caring for his family and being
under house arrest at the time of Thanos'
invasion.
We'll learn more about where he is exactly
in Ant-Man and the Wasp, the story of which
could potentially even provide a segue to
his role in Avengers 4.
Since Rudd was spotted on the set of the team-up's
production, it's safe to say he plays at least
a small part in the big story.
Black Panther
Chadwick Boseman's T'Challa was one of the
most surprising characters to bite the dust
at the end of Infinity War.
Though his exit was shocking, Boseman's presence
on the Atlanta set for Avengers 4 suggests
a relatively hasty return.
Considering the fact that Black Panther's
standalone film made over $1 billion at the
box office and has a sequel in the works,
it seems safe to assume that the king of Wakanda
will find his way back from the Necropolis
in Avengers 4.
Black Widow
Black Widow is one of the few characters who
survived the events of Infinity War, so it's
only natural that she come back for round
two.
And this time, she'll have a bigger role to
play.
Screenwriters Christopher Markus and Stephen
McFeely have acknowledged that Black Widow
ends up slightly sidelined in Infinity War,
and indicated that they couldn't afford to
give her as much screen time as fans might
have liked.
They felt comfortable pushing her into the
background because they knew there would be
more to come, for both her and Captain America.
According to Markus, "We realized they had
far more potential in the movie coming next
year, just in terms of how their characters
would be tested by the story."
Captain America
Chris Evans has been planning his exit from
the MCU for a while now, and it's highly likely
that Avengers 4 will mark his swan song as
Captain America.
Like Black Widow, it appears he'll have more
to do in the story in the next go-around.
Intriguing set pictures not only showed Evans
on the set of the fourth movie, but also wearing
his old costume from the first Avengers.
From a plot standpoint, the implications are
fascinating.
Are we going to see Cap get up to some time
travel?
Will there be two Captains Americas running
around, and the different suits are how we
tell them apart?
Wait, is that why Black Widow's blonde now?
Captain Marvel
We won't get the chance to officially meet
Brie Larson's Captain Marvel until the character's
standalone film comes out in March 2019, but
we did get our first tease of her entry into
the MCU thanks to Infinity War's post-credits
scene.
Considering that so many of the MCU's other
heroes are currently out of commission, it's
a sure bet that Captain Marvel will help save
the day in Avengers 4 one way or another.
Photos reportedly from the set of the movie
revealed her sporting a green variation of
her costume, and Josh Brolin has said he shot
at least one scene with Larson for the Infinity
War story's conclusion.
Falcon
Anthony Mackie's Falcon may have been snapped
out of existence in Infinity War, but he has
already assured fans that he'll be back for
the fourth film, sharing a picture of himself
relaxing on the movie's set.
Mackie's even gone so far as to offer up a
bit of a plot summary for fans in an interview
with MTV.
"A whole lot of people fighting.
A whole lot of people talking.
It's a war of infinity proportions, cut the
check."
Gamora
Gamora, played by Zoe Saldana met a particularly
tragic end in Infinity War, with Thanos sacrificing
his adopted daughter in order to obtain the
Soul Stone.
Considering that her demise occurred prior
to Thanos' universe-culling snap, it's a plot
turn that seemed like it might stick, that
is, until Saldana appeared to say otherwise.
Speaking to E! News, Saldana said her last
day on the set of Infinity War didn't feel
like "goodbye", but "to be continued".
The comment seems to confirm her involvement
in the fourth film, even if it doesn't necessarily
mean Gamora will be coming back to life.
Maybe she'll be glimpsed in flashback, or
stuck in a strange dimension inside of the
Soul Stone.
Whatever the specifics, it sure looks like
she'll be back.
Hawkeye
Fans were heartbroken over the absence of
Jeremy Renner's Hawkeye from Avengers: Infinity
War.
You never know, his bow and arrow could've
made the difference.
Like Ant-Man, Hawkeye was said to have taken
a house arrest deal with the government following
the events of Captain America: Civil War,
retiring from avenging to spend time with
his family.
But Renner has confirmed that he filmed for
Avengers 4.
More intriguingly, the actor was spotted on
set with a new haircut, covering up a costume
that looks suspiciously like the superhero
Ronin, an identity his character temporarily
assumed in the comics.
Regardless of which name he goes by, the screenwriters
have promised that Hawkeye will be a big part
of the fourth film, telling BuzzFeed, "We
like Hawkeye.
We like Hawkeye so much we gave him a really
good story."
Hulk
Mark Ruffalo's Bruce Banner had some performance
issues in the third Avengers movie, but at
least he made it out alive.
After spending a whole movie unable to summon
the Hulk, it seems fair to expect that his
powers will be returned to him at some point
in part four.
Ruffalo has said that Thor: Ragnarok and the
third and fourth Avengers films are designed
to form one Hulk storyline over three installments,
and it's a story likely to end with a bang.
Ruffalo was also spotted on set in a motion
capture suit, so either he's still inside
that Hulkbuster, or the big green guy is coming
back.
Iron Man
If you believe the rumors, then Avengers 4
could be the end of Tony Stark.
Although Robert Downey Jr. hasn't shared any
information on whether or not his character
will make it through Avengers 4, he has been
one of the more outspoken cast members when
it comes to hyping the film on social media.
From all the photos he's shared of his involvement
in the movie's production, we know for sure
that he will appear.
Whether he makes it out alive, well, that's
another story.
Mantis
Like most of the Guardians of the Galaxy,
Pom Klementieff's Mantis disintegrated at
the end of Infinity War.
Klementieff, though, has already seemingly
confirmed that she'll be back on board for
Avengers 4, sharing a photo of her make-up
trailer on social media.
It doesn't tell us anything about where she's
gone or how she's coming back, but it does
show that at least Mantis will be returning
for the next Avengers.
Additionally, Chris Pratt revealed in an Instagram
post that he'll be filming Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol. 3 with her in 2019.
It seems like Avengers 4 has no choice but
to get things back on track for the spacefaring
team before their next adventure.
Nebula
Karen Gillan's Nebula didn't exactly have
a smooth ride through Infinity War, but she
was one of the few characters that survived
the trip.
Not only will Nebula be back for Avengers
4, Gillan has shared a hope that her character
will be able to "somehow face her daddy issues
head-on" in the film.
For what it's worth, Nebula was also very
important to defeating Thanos in the comic
book version of the story, turning the tide
of battle by stealing the Gauntlet for herself.
Whether she makes the same move in the movie
or not, Infinity War perfectly sets up Nebula's
Avengers 4 arc for redemption, and revenge.
Scarlet Witch
Elizabeth Olsen's Scarlet Witch ended the
movie being thoroughly defeated, forced to
watch Vision's life end not just once, but
twice before being defeated herself.
Wanda is confirmed to come back to finish
the fight in Avengers 4, with Olsen sharing
a pic of a bruise she received on the set
during a flying scene.
Here's hoping we get to see the powerful Avenger
really unleash the chaos in the fourth movie.
With the love of her life being taken out
so cruelly by Thanos, she's never had more
to avenge.
Spider-Man
Tom Holland's Spider-Man had one of the most
brutal disappearing scenes in Infinity War,
but it's one that has the least impact when
you know what's going on behind the scenes.
We've known for some time that Holland will
be suiting up as Peter Parker again for a
second standalone film, which is set to hit
theaters just a few months after Avengers
4's release.
We also know he's a part of Avengers 4 because
he reportedly broke his nose on the set of
the production.
"Who said acting was easy huh?
Broken nose number three.
What a way to finish a movie."
Thanos will pay for this one.
Thor
Chris Hemsworth's Thor spent most of Infinity
War getting back to full power, and you can
bet he'll put that power to good use in Avengers
4.
Despite the fact that the character got a
stylish haircut in Thor: Ragnarok, Hemsworth
was spotted on set sporting the character's
old long-haired look, which again implies
either a flashback or some time travel in
store for the god of Thunder.
Vision
Paul Bettany's Vision got it the worst of
anyone in Infinity War, getting brutally put
out to pasture not just once, but twice.
Despite the fact that the Mind Stone that
gives him life is now embedded in Thanos'
Gauntlet, Bettany has confirmed that he'll
be back on board for the fourth movie.
The actor shared a picture of himself in full
Vision regalia, complete with Mind Stone,
in late 2017, filling out paperwork on the
set of Avengers 4.
While it seems safe to assume that Vision
will end up having to do more than just push
paper around when he comes back, it remains
unclear how he'll factor into the story.
Maybe Shuri managed to back up his memory
after all, and he can just go back to being
Iron Man's butler again.
War Machine
Don Cheadle's War Machine is one of the most
tenacious Avengers, always managing to bounce
back from what looks like certain doom.
As one of the few survivors of Infinity War,
the Iron Man sidekick will be needed more
than ever.
Both Josh Brolin and Gwyneth Paltrow have
said that they share scenes with Cheadle in
Avengers 4, making his involvement all but
certain.
Thanos is still out there, after all.
Rhodey's gatling gun has some work left to
do.
Wasp
Evangeline Lilly's Hope van Dyne is finally
suiting up to headline the relatively-lighthearted
Ant-Man and the Wasp.
It's one of the two Marvel films slated to
be released between Infinity War and Avengers
4, and leads up to an appearance by the Wasp
in the 2019 team-up.
While Lilly herself has confirmed that she'll
be a part of the fourth movie, she's also
said that you shouldn't expect too much of
her in the film.
According to a Q&A on her Instagram page,
she's "not going to be [in it] a ton."
However, she did say that she's "proud" and
"stoked" to be on board for the movie, adding
that she had "so much fun" on the film's set.
That's what happens when you show up just
in time for the happy ending.
Winter Soldier
Sebastian Stan's Bucky Barnes has had quite
the journey in the MCU, as his friendship
with Steve Rogers has been tested by time,
mind control, and more.
While this made his last moments in Infinity
War all the more heartbreaking, neither we
nor Steve have seen the end of Bucky Barnes
yet.
While Stan's remained tight-lipped about how
his character could be coming back, he has
confirmed that he filmed scenes for Avengers
4.
The actor has kept silent about the role he'll
play in the sequel's story, but we certainly
know what we want to see.
If Chris Evans really is leaving after his
next movie, well, someone's gotta be around
to pick up the shield.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!